I think Jake's will be president of the
United States for 2050. he personifies
the American dream if you look at
businesses there's only two things that
they really care about one do you have
capital and then two can you drive
attention Tick Tock Netflix YouTube sub
stack the New York Times for all
competitors it's a war of attention if
you look at Beast as an example I bet
you his returns are better than the top
Venture capitalists in the world all
right guys bang bang I've got Jeff here
with me uh you're a fascinating dude
you're an entrepreneur an investor uh a
culture critic you have uh kind of this
whole span of things but I think what a
lot of people in the tech world are
fascinated by is you run a fund called
the anti-fund uh with Jake Paul and when
people uh saw the announcement that you
and Jake Paul were going to do a fun
they were like all right we know Jeff
he's in Tech he's built companies like
he's legit
Jake is a YouTuber what is going on here
uh why partner with Jake on this and
what is the thought process behind
bringing together what are seemingly
completely two different worlds what
appears to have a lot of success so far
in terms of getting access to Deals and
making some great Investments
yeah well pump thanks for having on the
program I mean I think you were probably
one of my first Miami friends from The
Tech Community all coming here almost a
couple years ago
um well I think Jake's will be president
of the United States for 2050.
um and and I I actually generally
believe that he is one he's Ohio
Cleveland Midwestern boy swing state but
I also think he personifies the American
dream I mean he comes from his dad was
like a roofer his mom was a nurse and I
think his career in terms of dreaming
big
making mistakes making triumphs along
the way I think that's a very I think
it's a very inspiring story
um but all seriousness in terms of like
us linking Twitter but are you serious
about you think he really can become
president yeah yeah
um I I don't doubt that somebody from
like the internet culture will
absolutely become president of the
future is it just his background and
kind of his story that you think makes
him potentially become president or is
there something else in there I think
I'm more ambitious for him than himself
I think he's actually quite humble about
it
um
but I think in terms of like what I've
looked at in terms of political
dynasties a lot of it is name
recognition if you think about the
Clinton family the Bush family
in in some ways they are the aristocracy
of America these are generations of very
well-known families that have bush bush
bush Clinton Clinton repeated in the
media for decades and if you look at
this era of people who have their name
out in the public
I can't name many other people aside
from the Paul Brothers maybe the
Kardashians
um some of the YouTubers are up and
coming that have that compounding power
where like again like Jake is like 25
right his brother's like 27.
you do another 20 30 years of
compounding and assuming that they keep
doing great stuff don't make you know
don't [ __ ] up too badly Etc how much
power in terms of compounding interest
can you can you see the guys run with
yeah and what's fascinating is they
definitely started out as like Vine then
YouTube then they started to like kind
of be just famous for being famous homos
and now if you look you're like wait a
minute like Jake Paul's professional
boxer yeah Point Blank period anyone who
says anything else like you get in the
ring with them because not a lot of
people who are willing to do that and
then you look at Logan like he's a WWE
star right and so you're looking like
wait a minute how did this happen and
what actually isn't really that long of
a period of time like what is it 10
years or less maybe where they've made
these transitions into kind of the more
mainstream audiences and so your bet is
just like hey things in motion stay in
motion they're going to continue to do
this at a very high level for you know
two decades three decades I think it's
like the brand mode is actually very
very competitive right like if you're
looking at just like fashion brands or
consumer brands how much Capital how
much time is it going to take to compete
with apple Coca-Cola Louis Vuitton I
mean literally billions of dollars and
decades centuries of time
fortunately not fortunately human
lifespan is around 100 years so it's
like okay if you can start compounding
your name and brand and image when
you're in your teens 20s and also have I
think to your point which I think very
astute able to transition mediums
because I think most celebrities can
actually can't hot platforms like you're
a singer you're kind of in that lane
you're just like a business person
you're in that lane I think the
versatility to cross
uh different platforms and I think
Donald Trump personifies this right he
was real estate guy reality TV show guy
and then became president and it's like
okay it's actually quite genius quite
versatile and quite rare to be able to
be credible across so many different
platforms I think there is a reaction
against okay this person is too
ambitious he is out of his Lane let's
slap him down and I think there is that
antibody effect when when someone is too
ambitious I think there is a little bit
of this human instinct of like pulling
people down into their Lane yeah so
having this resiliency and maybe can I
say uncancelability to get hit be
resilient and then keep compounding I
think it's a very rare attribute from a
personality side you got to be kind of
crazy in terms of just like mental
resilience
and then some sort of Versatility genius
smoothness to be able to spot the trends
chameleon your personality your image
towards that new phenomenon and and ride
that uh macro like Tillman when you all
announced uh the fund what was the
reaction I saw the public reaction and
some of it was like haha this is
hilarious uh uh Jason kalkanis uh I
think you guys went back and forth with
him a little bit right and like I love
Jason because uh he's just as much
investor as he is Entertainer like he
really understands uh the internet uh
what was it in private did you guys get
messages of encouragement and support
were people like what are you guys doing
what did you personally get in terms of
were people like hey you're ruining your
career or like what was kind of the
feedback yeah I think uh
generally just super positive a very
thankful for Chris Dixon Mark Andreessen
from a16z being our first LPS uh had
done business with them previously and
it was great to see them believe in our
vision believe it in uh the execution
believe in what the potential could be
um but I think Jake and I
have a little bit of a troll personality
I think that's where there is actually a
lot of overlapping in terms of ambition
and kind of entertainment to ourselves
and to the world
um so I think when we saw Jason calcanus
like kind of troll us being like Oh yeah
basically hey Jeff you're ruining a
career like this like he's like terrible
I think we were just laughing I think it
was funny because I feel like Jason is
doing the same exact Playbook as we are
like he's out there saying some troll
stuff entertaining and on the side
writing a bunch of Syndicate money and
it's like hey like
in some sense like cool like
I mean I guess it's like it's
entertaining to that level but I think
what I think was like the core reason of
why we started the fun was that if you
look at businesses and what an
entrepreneurs and what they want from
their investors there's only two things
that they really care about one do you
have Capital because you need money to
pay for stuff and keep the lights on and
then two can you drive attention and I
think with anti-fun with the rise of
additional celebrity driven funds Kim
Kardashian just announced the new PE
fund I think that ladder where if
capital is more more and more of a
commodity being able to drive attention
in an increasingly noisy environment is
increasingly powerful so I don't think
it's necessarily maybe it was novel or a
bit of a stunt a couple years ago
but I think when you see the top tier VC
funds building podcasts building
newsletters
you know
getting celebrity Partners on board I
don't think that's changed I think it's
only going to accelerate towards people
that can drive Capital people that can
drive attention and those are the core
Commodities or levers that any business
needs to to thrive yeah when you start
looking at
um the Creator space I'm gonna use
Creator very Loosely here because I
always ask people like okay what's a
Creator is Donald Trump a Creator is a
journalist at the New York Times a
Creator like everyone is ultimately
competing uh for attention
um uh Rich over at uh um uh uh
uh light shed uh he's the person who I
think convinced me of this first where
he's like Tick Tock Netflix YouTube
sub stack the New York Times and like
your podcast or all competitors what are
you talking about and he was like it is
an attention game and ultimately they
are fighting you're gonna spend two
hours on your phone today or for many of
us six hours right eight hours I
recently saw a video uh where somebody
was asking uh some of the tick tock
Stars how many hours it was like 10 to
12 hours on their phone okay what are
they spending time on it is a it's a war
of attention and so when you see these
other creators that are all competing
for that who's doing it well like who do
you guys look at you're like that person
gets it that person has really nailed uh
kind of this model
uh I I we I think we're
at that realization if not
even more extreme on that realization
where
um a New York Times or Wall Street
Journal is like a basically
institutional blog yes and
some of the best writers from those very
storied Publications become Stars
themselves right and I think there's a
tension with the employees of these
media corporations becoming Superstars
and then starting their own corporations
right like folks like Kara swisser she
was a quote-unquote classic journalist
but I would argue that she's more of a
star now she has her own podcast runs
her own conference she wanted to raise a
VC fund I'm sure she could raise a VC
fund
um so to your point I think they're just
different labels and different flags
that you can kind of wrap around who are
like hey I'm gonna have more of a
journalistic
I want to be a you know the fifth wall a
fourth wall version of a content creator
or I'm gonna be the star myself and have
my uh my personal conflicts of interest
and personality out there and I think
with uh more politicization of these
institutional Publications I think the
public perception is that everyone is
just biased anyways of course you're
human how how does anybody say I'm not
biased like you're full of [ __ ] you are
definitely biased you may write in a way
that uh removes bias or mitigates it or
tries to hide it or whatever but like at
the end of the day if we ask anybody
whether it's politics it's Finance it's
just uh kind of General coverage do you
agree that this person is right or wrong
or do you you know what's your stance on
this topic they have opinions what they
are biased and I think it's healthy if
we all just accept it right like does
not have this fake hypocrisy like hey
I'm actually just like the truth uh
dictator and everyone else has got to
like listen
um but the answer is a direct question I
think
um
I think in terms of the groups or teams
that are working really well on just a
broad content creator side I would say
that Mr Beast night media executing
super well milk Boys full send exiting
super well and I think like but I think
like even like looking up to you like I
think what you're doing from the tech
investment content side I mean like
there's a method to the madness in terms
of just like pumping out content in
shorts I mean I think
it's actually interesting in terms of
innovators dilemma right like the old
school institutions have to monetize
through ads and uh subscription Revenue
but I think what we're seeing with such
these celebrity Brands is that
oftentimes owning Brands owning merch
owning Equity formation is actually a
more durable business model and Founders
like yourself and Beast and what we're
doing with anti-fun we can actually do
company formation yeah where like the
old school guys have to be like hey like
we can't launch companies out of our
following so this is a fascinating topic
that requires understanding of history
but if you go back uh and I'm going to
get some of the exact details wrong but
generally uh sequoia's first fund was in
like the 1950s I remember correctly and
in it there was about nine Investments
give or take uh I think three of them
were incubated companies so they had an
idea they partnered with some uh
Founders they put some capital in and
they owned an outsized uh portion of the
business and then the remainder uh
remaining part of the fund was all uh
outside investment just traditional
venture capital of that uh two of the
three companies they incubated delivered
majority of the returns for that fund
now part of it was the companies worked
another part of it was they had outsized
uh ownership of the business uh but that
is really the like dawn of venture
capital was actually incubating plus
putting Capital out in into minority
positions in other companies now the
reason why that's interesting is because
over a 50 60 almost 70-year time frame
we have seen much less incubation and
people just were like oh it's so much
easier to just find people and just give
them money and get smaller and smaller
ownership to now there's people who make
investments that could be millions of
dollars when they get like half a
percent of a business right
but what we are starting to see and what
you're getting at here is like the new
Venture capitalists are not people just
with funds looking to invest in other
people's things the new Venture
capitalists are showing up and like
we're returning back to the 1950s of
Sequoia and like we can build the
companies better than other folks
because there's distribution there's
compounding knowledge which is actually
a very underrated thing and then there's
either access to Capital where they're
able to raise funds and do all this or
just like the businesses are so
profitable that they have the cash flow
to actually go and and uh and build
these and so like if you look at Beast
as an example like Jimmy's launched how
many businesses in the last two years I
can think of just off the top of my head
uh he has all the different channels
here's the translation service for other
YouTubers he has the uh Beast Burger he
has the chocolate bars right and there's
probably others that I'm not even
thinking of
and you're like that dude's not a
Creator like that guy literally owns a
private Equity Fund or like an incubator
and he is outperforming everyone else
like I bet you his returns are better
than the top Venture capitalists in the
world yeah I I mean he literally just
raised a hundred million dollar fund
with the Turning group so they are going
down that path and
I mean I think even if you look at just
traditional enterprise software
companies snowflake was essentially
incubated out of Sutter Hill Ventures
right and I think it's like to the point
that you see these like emergent random
super big software companies like a lot
of these have like very
calculated strategic capital and go to
market and I think again going back to
what I think are the core Commodities
one acts the capital which
goes back to relationships and trust and
then proven distribution Advantage which
again takes it takes a lot of time and
energy to get your brand and be trusted
as someone that can offer a great uh
product or service
um and then I think just with in my
entrepreneurial career you're seeing
that
um
those two things compound
and and are just quite actually
defensive moats and you just see that
the people that do it really really well
have really great access to Capital and
really great access to distribution
um so again if you just boil down if you
didn't have anything if you could be the
best coder the best marketer
um oftentimes if you can guarantee
capital and distribution you can hire
those people so I think like the
conversation of what is the best
strategy as a Founder individually to do
company formation and then how do you
partner with operators
I think it's actually a good time to
just pull back and think hey from first
principles what are the most important
things to double down on so people will
hear us talking about this like who who
the [ __ ] are these guys right uh you
built a business hvmn uh which uh has
built a ton of different products but I
think the story of how you've built some
of these products really shows kind of
the the blocking and tackling the
execution of not only being able to
build products but then go sell those
products so talk to us a little bit as
to that first business like how did you
come up with the idea of going after
this and why did you think it was such a
big enough opportunity to spend your
time and energy yeah
um even before eight uh hvm and our
Ketone IQ are our Ketone drink company I
actually studied computer science at
Stanford had a little mobile app company
and at the time why commentator was like
fairly new we were helping Paul Graham
and Jessica Livingston throw like
startup school and events at Stanford
campus so I got to know uh the YC people
pretty early
um so me and a couple buddies decided to
start like a mobile app company long
story short is called glass map it was
very very early in the social location
mobile space we bought the most
efficient battery tracking algorithm for
mobile so this is before location
services it was like early early iOS
where
tracking your location on on iOS so
drain your battery in three four hours
so we had a instead of a
long story short we had a really smart
algorithm in kind of hijacking the VoIP
voice over IP hook very control your
data so it's server driven in terms of
location tracking versus uh device or or
uh local driven
um long story short
um met this is Mark Zuckerberg because
they were looking at acquiring the space
um and this is like three months after
we launched and I think we had very big
entrepreneurial dreams we turned down a
acquisition offer there at a pre-ipo
Facebook campus it was kind of
do you regret it do you regret it yeah
we would have made way more money than
eventually selling the Groupon which is
also a great outcome for being like 23
24 at the time
um but I actually don't regret it in the
sense that like
it's very easy to just to be arrogant
when you're getting very early success
and I think that like six nine twelve
months of like getting an acquisition
interest and then just grinding and be
like hey like we were growing linearly
but not exponentially and in startup
land if you're not growing exponentially
or nothing yep right that's just a
polarized business model and outcomes
and then we pivot it to B2B and just
like really grinding like kind of more
SMB sales eventually our technology got
a couple patents from it so I own a
couple software algorithm patents that
we sold the group on and then we were
part of the merchant OS team so we're
very very early in the wallet uh Point
of Sales you know we're talking with the
square team as well to make a bidding
Dynamic for the acquisition
um but just getting some real brass
tacks of like hey it's actually friggin
hard to make money and make something of
value was really useful for me as like a
21 22 23 year old yeah I think if I just
punched out made millions of dollars at
23 after like launching something that
like didn't really actually have a lot
of users or actually add a lot of
utility
I think added resiliency and
understanding that's probably worth more
than like the initial upfront like quick
flip that would have gotten yeah well
it's uh it's fascinating too because
it's right out of school so like there's
like the theoretical kind of academic
world yeah which uh obviously if you
study computer science like you're going
to get uh uh education you're gonna get
knowledge you're gonna get some like
experience in the classroom but to then
go out and if you almost just like do it
like I've had this where you have quick
success doing something in here like
you're just like hella I'm a [ __ ]
genius yeah yeah
it's better to then get punched in the
face and be like no no hold on a second
like there is this grind to it because
it then uh serves you better later on
right no 100 today's episode is brought
to you by Exodus you can use exodus to
buy crypto for zero fees for a limited
time they just launched a brand new
wallet that allows you to use one wallet
across all the different networks
ethereum Solana polygon whatever else
you want to use if you go to exodus.com
pump you can go ahead and use that
wallet or you can buy Bitcoin ethereum
or any other crypto asset you can use
your bank account out your credit card
Apple pay or Google pay Exodus is here
for you head on over to exodus.com pomp
today to get started exodus.com pump
they support us you go support them
um so that so having that again it's
relatively early success I would say
that it gave me time to explore and I
just really got into biohacking and
Human Performance and I think
it was just like tinkering with
nootropics ketogenic diet fasting so if
you remember in like 2015
um there's like a bunch of Articles and
media around Silicon Valley biohackers
and smart drugs Silicon Valley people
and fasting and all this stuff and maybe
I can claim a little bit of credit there
like we eventually ran the largest
online biohacker community based out of
Silicon Valley so we had like 80 000
people like doing fasting and all these
experiments with us
um and that was like kind of my first
iteration through a lot of podcasting
content we had like Netflix show time
and all these different like shows come
and watch me eat like raw meat and
what's the craziest thing what's the
craziest thing you did
um probably like
I did a seven day water fast so it
didn't eat any food for seven days okay
what happens when you do that like what
would your body go through
uh well your body goes into ketosis
which it runs out of storage
carbohydrate stored sugar it starts
eating or you start converting your body
fat into energy so you know our bodies
are actually quite resilient when I
first embarked on this and this is after
studying the literature and talking to
doctors and and phds
I thought that like it was actually just
impossible not to eat for like two days
or one day right like it's like hey like
like you're my I remember my mom be like
don't skip meal it was bad for you right
your breakfast
um I think the biggest learning I got
from it was
uh
actually understanding stimulus uh and
and how your body interprets things and
I think I realized I I finally
understood what true hunger is versus
the Board I am phys like literally
neurochemically bored I want a dopamine
hit by like drinking something of and
having some like Flavor in my mouth or
I'm like literally bored sitting so I
need to like move around and go consume
something
um and that in Brock Donna just get
self-exploration around reading a lot of
Eastern philosophy Western philosophy
meditation and I think where it applied
a little bit more to business is that I
realized that most of our stress is
intellectual
stress and we actually
our bodies are adapted towards
responding to physical danger so
essentially if you I have like a like a
legal problem or a business problem your
body naturally reacts as if you're going
into a fight or flight fight right
adrenaline dumps you're literally trying
to fight someone your heart rate goes up
and
going through fasting understanding what
true hunger was versus like false board
hunger I think was very informative for
me to from a mental resilience
perspective realize that basically every
single business
or modern civilization problem is not a
physical someone's trying to kill you
problem it's someone is like suing you
or like there's a business negotiation
or like you have a conflict with your
boss but it's like a very intellectual
and
decreasing your physical response like
just mentally be like hey no one's
trying to kill me
like calm F down
and just process it like very cold
logically ruthlessly from a rational
perspective has been very very helpful
as like a hack to be able to deal with a
lot of uh requests and stressful
situations
um because I think it is actually very
scary when like you have your first
legal dispute or contract dispute or
business dispute or like a negotiate a
salary or a new job
and oftentimes you're like in this fight
mode and oftentimes being trying to
fight someone
or run away from someone in that
conversation is actually very very bad
for outcome so I think through all this
physical biohacking experimentation I
think it just really made me attune
towards
the natural evolutionary pathway of how
to respond to stimuli live versus like
what is the more rational
logical way given that we're in a very
very different game like most the
problems that all of us deal with are
modern civilizational games versus like
physical I'm going into a fight uh
scenario yeah and so as you're going
through this process like there's almost
like a self-exploration right there's
like a oh I learned something that's
cool maybe I tell my friends you start a
company right like like why start a
company and how did you think about like
the commercial uh kind of value or
opportunity versus just being like hey
I'm a badass now because I understand
how you know the human body works better
than the people I deal with on a daily
basis maybe I can use that to like my
own Advantage yeah like I think actually
just actually quite uh
tactical so at the time in circa 2014
nootropics which is like a like a
technical term for brain enhancing
compounds supplements uh
the Reddit Community was growing quickly
and the natural Google Trends was
growing quickly
um so I felt like at the time there was
like
untapped growing Community behind this
exploration or this revisiting of can I
enhance my cognitive ability through
diet Behavior exercise Etc
um and then it was very uh like Lean
Startup mode I coded the a little
landing page on Ruby on Rails
um and was taking pre-order so it's
basically like a day of like buying
domain neutrabox.com at the time getting
a pre-sales landing page hooking into
stripe and collecting credit cards and
then posting on Hacker News like that
was like the experiment at the time I
remember we got 34 pre-orders for like
30 bucks of product at the time so I
pre-sold a thousand bucks of Revenue and
I was kind of crazy enough to be like yo
I I should just fulfill them
and we just didn't really stop and then
we I think it was like three four months
later or like six months later we were
doing like 80k a month of sales just
like rinse repeat like like ah I I guess
we gotta just freaking do this now yeah
uh so that's like a million run rate
business and I was like okay uh maybe we
should kind of scale this up properly go
from like hobbyist
um Homebrew version of nootropic
supplements so like hey let's actually
develop uh you know hire phds build out
a proper supply chain and all of that
and I think that's been an amazing
platform to go from nootropics into
fasting into eventually acquiring IP and
and and know-how from a DARPA research
program it described this process
because uh for those who don't know uh
there's this Ketone IQ uh that recently
has come out it's a daily Ketone
supplement uh I took about I don't know
is it 15 milliliters uh is that right uh
before we started I think I'm high right
now
um you're supposed to take what 30 or so
a day so maybe halfway through um I'll
come down and do it again
um but uh when I saw this come out I was
like oh this isn't like uh uh in my head
I was like this isn't [ __ ] right like
this isn't like hey we just like read
some books and decided to come up with
something like there's like real science
to this so describe a little bit about
this process of like going to DARPA
getting the actual IP and then being
able to commercialize it with great
success so far yeah
um so as I was going down that rabbit
hole of biohacking human performance
um
essentially like self-taught like pretty
Advanced levels of metabolic
biochemistry and around 2016 2017 there
was a number of published literature
showing that uh exogenous consumable
ketones are able to hands cycling
performance and enhance uh physical
endurance and this is on the backdrop of
me really getting to fasting me getting
the ketogenic diets me experimenting the
carnivore diet so I remember I see like
liver King running around all the time
like I was doing like two-month blocks
of carnivore back in like 2016 2017 so
it's cool to see kind of that
re-emergence of some of these like
interesting axiomatic principles of
nutrition bull testicles uh did not was
able we didn't go for both testicles was
eating a lot of liver actually yeah I'd
actually like awful like it's actually
very standard in other Cantonese Chinese
cuisine I'm just like eating this stuff
I was like growing up as a kid so I was
like oh okay like I will compete with
liver King on eating liver man like
let's go I'm not afraid of that
um I like eating weird stuff it's
actually one of my Pleasures
um that sounded weird
but um so so in the in the substrate of
like doing a lot of fasting really
understanding ketosis and then realizing
that hey
um it's actually
really hard to like not eat for three
days not eat for seven days I remember
it like the first few times just like
feelings like not being able to really
sleep on day two day three or that that
evening because of hunger or your body's
not used to just like yeah your body's
like hey I'm starving like Jeff wake up
go hunt and eat yeah um you're dying
right yeah
um but that'd be very interesting after
you pass uh this the third night your
hunger actually attenuates you feel very
Zen it's like you're very clear
um so I think when you hear these
stories of
I believe you know Socrates for his
Academy he would have students fast for
10 days before joining the Academy I
think there's a lot of this tradition of
both religious and academic and
philosophical traditions of people
fasting before going and entering the
school as a proof of devotion but also
just like a a clarification of mind also
just very interesting but like shamanic
rituals of plant Menace In Ayahuasca is
like purging and fasting involved with
it too I think there's a lot of
interesting cultural substrate around
this notion of fasting and purification
and clearing your mind so I think
there's a lot of little I would say like
Lindy cultural things that say that hey
there's something too fasting right
Moses was fasting G you know all these
like biblical stories about people
fasting
um
so if I can skip the pain of and the
discipline of fasting and just like
drink ketones and get a lot of the
benefits that seems like it's super
massive problem to solve yep
um and apparently in the early 2000s
DARPA also had asked that same question
can uh
scientists create a liquid super field
that gets you a more efficient energy
source
um
and it's a kind of a crazy story because
uh the vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff this gentleman General Peter
Pace who was the first Marine General
that became a chairman of the Joint
Chiefs was the vice chairman of DARPA at
the time and actually signed off on this
research program called operation
metabolic dominance
what a [ __ ] badass yeah it sounds
badass
um and now you know essentially almost
you know 20 years later he's on her
board helping us in advising us on how
to take this and scale this technology
up to the to the to the to the next uh I
guess the stage but at the time
um one dose of this was cost twenty five
hundred dollars
so one dose being 30 milliliters like
yeah like basically 10 25 grams of
ketones yep would cost twenty five
hundred dollars and is that because of
uh bureaucracy with military
pharmaceutical industries that because
of the materials like the technology to
manufacture so uh like many organic
chemicals is a carbon backbone it's like
it's a carbon-based molecule ketones so
our body naturally converts fat fatty
acids in the liver called ketogenesis
into these Ketone bodies so it's just
like a organic chemistry process that
your liver does uh when it's under the
presence of no no glucose hanging around
or low glucose hanging around
um so the original technology to convert
uh into these ketones was taking crude
oil
in processing petroleum product into
these exogenous ketones so very dirty
very expensive very complicated process
but what happened in in recent years is
that with the rise of synthetic biology
we could actually code genetically
engineered E coli to ferment sugar into
the precursors into the strength so
really it was a technology technology
breakthrough not like actually not a
bureaucracy breakthrough so
by fermenting sugar with with bugs a
much more efficient process so it took
you know we had a version one of this
product that cost thirty dollars a dose
and a lot of our customers were Tour de
France teams MMA athletes and that was
actually my initial for eight getting to
know a lot of athletes
um
you know getting to know Lance Armstrong
Apollo Ono and then you know Conor
McGregor's the Royal Jake Paul's the
world is actually all due through
ketones and then and they were on like
some search they knew that hey if I can
get deeper and deeper into ketosis uh my
metabolism and my kind of metabolic
Health all this stuff will improve and
therefore I can be more dominant at my
Sport and so they were already kind of
in the science and trying to find the
stuff or would you guys go and be like
hey I know you're you know gifted as an
athlete but like there's this whole
science thing you should learn about so
that you can get it's actually the
former so I think what I realized being
able to work with you know the tip of
the spear Elite operators in the
military and Elite athletes and like
business folks or entrepreneurs and Tech
folks like ourselves
I think everyone
is just like smart and Savage about
winning yes and like the very very elite
athletes are just super disciplined and
super structured around gaining edges
right like sport is how do you get
an unfair advantage that's fair against
your opponents same with business same
with every single Endeavor of humanity
that's that's competitive right you're
just trying to find advantage and I
would say over the last couple decades
like the nutrition and training regimens
of cycling nutrition cycling workouts
right there's like this whole notion of
recovery is super important and you're
cycling like heavy uh workouts and then
we're backing off and doing recovery
um
I would say like the most elite athletes
are also doing nutrition you'll have
like you will lower your carbohydrate
intake in pre-season just to really ramp
up your fat oxidation right you're
almost starving your body forcing your
body to get really really efficient and
then when you're getting closer
competition engorge it with like all the
nutrition possible so you're just super
flush with energy when you go into your
Olympic match or your boxing match your
MMA match so this notion of exercise
cycling and the nutrition cycling
it's like that is what people are you
know full-time professionals are
studying this and part of these teams
and if you look at Just Sports Medicine
Sports physiology before like in the
early 1900s it's like a gentleman's
sport right like you just were like a
rich person that had like your family
estate you're gonna just go run the
marathon or you know compete with other
gentlemen
um and then I would say a little bit
more professionalized there's like a a
coach that would like teach you
everything hey do this do this workout
do the nutrition and now you look at
sports departments
strength and conditioning specialists
nutrition specialist recovery specialist
I mean I think just seeing like Jake's
Jake Paul's specific Camp I mean he is
like actually crazy sophisticated with
like literally a full-time breath coach
a full-time like stretching and and like
yoga coach like multiple boxing coaches
a strength and conditioning coach a chef
nutritionist and I think that's actually
quite commonplace with the elite teams
in the military as well as Elite sports
team so I would say like the whole
sophistication has gotten very very uh
granular because like the difference
being gold and I don't know 10 places
like so fractional at this time yeah
um when you see that
do you think this will get into business
as well it's like we already see I don't
know like the super wealthy they have
private Chef or they have you know some
components of this they don't think of
it so much as uh maybe performance as
they think about it as it's saving them
time or for their family to make uh life
easier or whatever but do we know of
stories where there are founders who uh
have very specialized uh coaches for
their own physical body not hey I have a
coach that I talk to uh you know for
business strategy or something like that
but like actual physical optimization as
uh uh performing in the business
environment
I mean I I think people talk less about
it but maybe like one just very visible
example is Jeff Bezos definitely is on
some optimization right like I mean he's
what in his 50s and he's just like
ripped ripped right like you don't
suddenly add 20 30 pounds of lean muscle
tissue without some hormone optimization
and all of that
um and this is not like uh he just like
bought some uh steroids off a [ __ ]
website that came from like China and
he's like doing like self-administration
like you're saying he's literally going
to see a a physician like a doctor who
specializes in it they're measuring his
blood work probably they're they're
trying to understand yeah that's such an
interesting point I mean I didn't think
about that angle but yeah there are
actually a lot of concierge private
doctors who cater to Tech billionaires
and performance right so they're like
and this is like a very interesting
thing of just like modern American
Healthcare which is I think it's you
know people talk about really a sick
care right you really only go to the
doctor when it's like I don't know I've
got some problem yeah
um but I think the most optimized CEOs
Founders and investors that are in in
our circles they're getting their bloods
done every month every quarter
fine-tuning everything is that what you
do like what what is your regiment both
uh exercise maybe like uh from a
physician in interaction and then also
uh from a diet or nutrition
is it okay X the new race car maybe but
actually no okay X is one of the world's
leading crypto trading apps okay
yeah so yeah so like when I was like
super measuring everything I was doing
monthly blood draws optimizing every
single micronutrient hormone levels just
I guess an analogy is that like we have
Dash real-time dashboards for your
business yes you probably know more
about your car health and your your
house your apartment health and what
like for a lot of Americans like we go
we like hate to go maybe go to once a
year maybe once a couple years just get
some baseline panels
um
it it seems backwards for like we should
be getting real-time dashboards of just
all our bodies metrics
so
it's very time intensive just I don't
know I don't like being stuck with
needles
um so but I think in terms of just like
understanding what you can do I think
it's actually quite material when it's
like oh like my vitamin D levels and I
think most people's vitamin D levels are
very very low
um because we're just indoors all the
time
um so I think all these things that we
should be tracking because like our
bodies are our most valuable asset we're
not really doing so I think when there's
like companies that like are you know
levels with the CGM and I think eight
sleep you know mutual friend is tracking
HRV and sleep metrics I think it's all
directionally in the right way of how to
be better humans right like we should be
metrics driven on on our bodies yeah why
is testosterone falling so aggressively
this is like the the thing that whenever
I talk to people who uh maybe are like
uh surface level educated they're always
like oh testosterone's falling you know
every 20 years it's like getting cut in
half or whatever do you have thoughts
there or have you guys looked at any of
this stuff in terms of one is it
important that it's falling right like
should we be concerned about it and then
any ideas as to why that's happening
yeah I think it's actually just like a
very open scientific question
um I think the leading hypothesis is
there's just a lot of EP like
uh bpas uh in in uh essentially like
Plastics that are uh estrogen mimicking
compounds are just floating around in
the environment
um a lot of like fragrances
are estrogenizing so a lot of the modern
environment and modern like
niceties of pla like disposable Plastics
fragrances cleaning materials
um all Impact your hormone levels so one
I think it is a real problem
um and I think there's also just like a
lot of like funny things for like for
example like nicotine actually is like
it's anti or aromatizing so if it stops
the conversion of testosterone to
estrogen so with the reduction of like
nicotine is probably a good thing
um compounded with prevalence of of
plastics and then uh increase in obesity
and diabetes so uh the conversion the
aromatization of testosterone into
estrogen is caused primarily happens in
your uh adipose tissue so if we as a
society are getting fatter with more
adipose tissue there are more sites for
conversion of testosterone to estrogen
so I think it's like uh
all these environmental factors these
metabolic factors that are causing this
reduction of testosterone
um
do I think it's a good or bad thing
I think it's it's a very material thing
like I don't have like a
a prior judgment on
T and estrogen but if it's a mixed
science experiment over the last 20 30
50 years where Humanity has succeeded
and not killed ourselves over the last
Millennia and now we're running this
experiment where
the hormone levels of half of humanity
are changing quite drastically over a
year measurable year-to-year period I
think it's potentially very very
dangerous I mean I think you can kind of
start speculating does that impact
politics that does that impact culture
does that impact societal preferences
look we can kind of speculate there and
you could probably get into trouble by
expecting a little bit too far
um but I think it
at least like that's something that I
care about personally right like if I
were to advise myself or friends like
hey look I've been talking to friends
like hey get your T levels measured
um and it's actually very surprising
like
being able to have these conversations
with athletes uh with entrepreneurs
actually a lot of my friends who are in
their 20s that are high level athletes
high-level entrepreneurs actually have
very low T levels yeah some part of what
their grandfathers are right I don't
know if it's through the stress
environment you know having that you
know extra drink on the weekend because
you're stressed out all these things
actually compound
um I think there's a lot of great
literature how testosterone actually
makes
effort feel good I mean I just like it
actually impacts neurochemistry so I
think from a productivity
a traditional masculinity perspective I
think these are like very very like
important questions I think when you
have you know I really enjoyed your
conversation with Andrew Tate like I
think he's opening up questions and
conversations around what is traditional
masculinity is there a place
in this modern world and I think it'd be
it would be
silly to think that changing
testosterone levels does not contribute
to that conversation yeah it um people
can't listen to the conversation on
YouTube because they took it down
go to Apple podcast
um when you put this into my body I just
for those uh they didn't see I just took
another 15 milliliters of this so I
think I'm topped out for the day uh it's
10 grams of ketones per serving what the
hell is going on in my head like why do
I feel like uh maybe I like clear or
sharper or high whatever you whatever
terminal you want to use
um what is this actually doing to my
body yeah so I should have asked that
before I took it I love it you took it
first so I figured we were good that's a
true friend
um so ketones are actually a preferred
energy for the brain so ketones cross
the blood brain barrier and when there's
presence of ketones your brain actually
metabolizes ketones in preference the
glucose so the really cool thing about
ketones is that now we're going to go
into uh like high school bio if you
remember the Krebs cycle the ATP cycle
um
we have mitochondria which are kind of
the power plants of the cells it takes
energy and oxygen and it converts in and
turns into ATP the energy currency
so the cool thing about ketones is that
ketones produce more ATP per oxygen so
it's literally at the biochemical level
more efficient than sugar
so that is like one of the key reasons
why
um some of the research we're doing with
the military relate to uh cognition
reaction time at high altitude so if you
think about taking people up to 40 000
feet think Afghanistan mountain ranges
when you have less oxygen your reaction
time slows your decision making slows if
there are energy substrates that can
produce more ATP per unit oxygen When
there's less oxygen available and you're
able to preserve function that's very
useful from a military application but
of course from like a
like an intellectual Creator you know
application very useful as well yeah
it's a fascinating conversation right
now because
um I recently I had Kyle Larson a pretty
well known Navy SEAL uh and we were
talking
um about all of the controversy in Seal
training and so now there's people who
are claiming like oh there's like
rampant steroid use and like all this
crazy stuff and I'm like dude y'all want
to know uh what was going on in every
single military school I ever went to
like people were popping Advil right
because like their bodies hurt right and
like is that is that rampant is that
abuse is that whatever like I don't know
but I can tell you that uh in the
military guess where else that was super
popular in a college football locker
room where guys were taking Percocets
and all kinds of stuff before they went
and played right and so like you start
to look at this you're like man okay so
we know people are gonna take things
because either on an edge they want to
uh contain pain they want recovery they
want whatever but a lot of in the
military specifically it's like what can
we put on the soldier so it's like let's
give them night vision cool we've like
now made this like thing that can see in
the night and our Warriors can go out in
the night when other people can't see
right we've got Scopes we've got body
armor we've got like all these things
that are external to the body that we
are essentially trying to create like
the RoboCop soldiers right to whatever
degree you then supplement that with
things like Andrew which I know you guys
invested in in terms of uh better
intelligence better information better
uh technology but really what you're
talking about is like well what happens
if we also could improve the soldiers in
the military use case from the inside
out and going on a 10 mile run as fast
as you possibly can to some degree is
trying to strengthen the body and build
endurance and like do all this stuff but
like there's probably other things that
we can do and if we have our soldiers
eating cupcakes all day versus eating
like a healthy diet like they're being
coached to eat healthy not eat [ __ ] so
what is the difference between like
don't smoke cigarettes you know don't
eat a bunch of sugar and like oh by the
way drink this drink that is going to
help you in some way like it feels like
a natural extension to me yeah
um yeah I mean I think one of the
coolest career experiences that you know
through hvnb we became a military
contractors so we have a multi-million
dollar contract with Special Operations
Command and
like getting to know service members
really at the tip of the spear and
sharing their stories
I mean being a California La born raise
and then a Stanford can be like just a
California kid and just like
going to Fort Bragg and Virginia Beach
and
like you know Georgia right like it's it
was like I felt like I just understood
America much better
um by spending time with these guys
um like they truly believe in this
country I mean they're they're bleeding
and and had
yeah
and and people you know like Risk like
lost their lives like defending our way
of life so it's been like I think one of
the honestly like one of the Privileges
of the coolest parts of my career so far
um
but I think that
um
there's actually like interesting like
bureaucracy and like Contracting uh
related stuff where you have to be
careful about human experimentation
there's actually like a very interesting
I would say like regulatory Contracting
vehicles that we've just gotten exposure
and a lot of learning from
um so
I think there's a lot of good effort by
uh the general staff the senior ncos
um and then the civilian staff looking
to improve the process because I think
it's it's you're actually right like
it's much easier to just like have a
better widget to install on on someone's
over someone's body versus like Hey how
do we take care of the individual
service member
um without Crossing Lines of human
experimentation ethics human safety all
of that
um so I think and it's probably the
right approach you got to be a little
bit more thoughtful
um because I think going back to like
even just like steroids and all this
stuff I my experience has been that the
the higher tier units they're like super
locked down in terms of like what they
can take and what they can't take and
they're just very very serious about it
so
probably the right approach to be
relatively conservative with dealing
with our you know the tier one operators
that really the tip of the spear for our
country
um but can we have a little bit more
speed a bit more Innovation I mean
hopefully that kind of the Silicon
Valley approach
uh it can speed things up and I think to
your point around Android I think
it's great to have new blood new
approaches mix in with like
institutional safeties yeah uh one of
the things with Andrew specifically that
like blows my mind is when I think of uh
the big Prime contractors like I think
about lobbying I think about like
dinners suits and ties like there's just
for whatever reason it's an over
generalization but like there's a lot of
uh just like it's a machine it moves at
a machines Pace uh and it's more based
on like you know us you trust us uh you
like us and like we can get uh this done
efficiently whereas Andrew showed up and
was like yeah that's all cool but like
we have a better [ __ ] widget right
and I do think that we're seeing this
across Society right if you if you think
a lot about uh go back to the media for
example like there's a lot of
Publications that just kind of were like
resting on their Laurels being like you
know us you trust us we're kind of the
big institution you know chill out we'll
get you the information efficiently and
then somebody else just showed them was
like no like you guys are wrong I have a
different opinion and like this is like
something that people want yeah and so
do you see that when you're actually
evaluating markets and businesses I know
you guys built like archive.com as an
example like it just seems one of the
the key pieces to your career the
threads through it is that you guys
actually are going after markets that
people have been looking at for a while
but it's in some new unique way or with
some new you know type of approach that
ends up actually being fairly disruptive
I think you have to believe that if
you're in in a in a or an upstart
position and I think
I feel like history is on our side where
there is this innervators dilemma this
uh
this this this sludge at a cruise when
it's like the third fourth fifth
generation for the ownership and the
vision is really diluted across managing
professional money Bean counters
um
yeah I mean I think for
I mean I I like I I think just even for
like
like currency right like you know I
think we talked a lot about crypto and I
think last year was like a crazy time
for crypto
um
like I I want a world where people can
choose better systems to partake in I
mean I think it would suck
to be forced to you know like I when I
see like British royalty I think it's
like kind of crazy that like hey they're
literally having to pledge their
allegiance and their like I feel very
lucky to be American I pledge allegiance
to a flag or a constitution or an idea
but literally our friends over across
the pond literally the pledge to a queen
or a king and it's like damn like I
thought this is like some Game of
Thrones stuff like you got literally
Bend and need to get a award from like
some nice you know friendly Elder the
queen was getting a dollar ahead from
every person who lived in Australia
still like there's a dollar ahead tax on
every Australian because it was like
still uh a queen you know land or
whatever yeah like yo [ __ ] that and I
and I get that like there's a reason why
it's there How They Came Upon it there's
no one who's been like disrupting it a
lot of times when it comes to this
geopolitical stuff there has to be like
Revolution and War and like all these
things that actually people who have
been exposed to that stuff are like hey
you want to avoid that at all costs and
only use it as a last resort but it is
wild in 2022 that the citizens of
Australia were paying a tax someone who
lives across the world yeah in their
private estate and then and then like
the queen is able to just transfer all
our assets to Charles right just like oh
man like different roles being played
um so like I think like
yeah and I think when you look at that
when you step back like hey like there's
just a lot of like systems with
government that might have made sense at
the time a lot of Legacy a lot of
institution but like can we rewrite
today
um
I think if you and I just were deciding
like things to like Start Anew like I
think we'd build a lot of things
differently and I think a lot of people
that are listening probably think the
same way so when it is looking at new
opportunities and new approaches I think
that's what we live breathe and we'll
dive on that's a hill we'll die on
um that's just how we operate like I I
want to operate in a way where I look at
every single human whether you're uh
Barista or you're the queen or King of
England I want to treat you the same I
want to be treated the same as well
right like just treat me as an
individual not some weird Legacy
institutional thing
um so hopefully that I think has
that core Axiom has trickled into how I
think about business formation so for
archive
um
so two three years ago we were you know
one of the primary direct uh marketing
channels and distribution channels was
e-commerce right we were pretty early on
building our own e-commerce stack moving
over to Shopify just seeing how everyone
is doing the same Facebook CAC LTV
equation can you acquire and get paid
back within three months six months 12
months uh and then optimizing your
landing pages to like reduce your
customer acquisition costs right there's
like a math problem that every single
DTC company was doing
um I think people got really really good
into it good about it
um but we were quite metrics driven
around like hey like a lot of the like
reported results were actually very very
soft
um and I would say two three years ago
we realized the power of actual
community and just thinking what is the
first principles of marketing it's just
like an extended way of like Goodwill
like how do you get people talking
positively on your brand and how do you
actually uh manage a digital community
so archive really came from this Insight
that hey doing this that like the
pay-to-play run Facebook run Google and
then maybe have temperature to spend on
random other like Snap and and other
stuff
probably wasn't going to be sustainable
I think now that's that has come true
uh so we just built a lot of software
automation how do you run a community
how do you actually trigger community
events uh from someone for example
posting about your brand so
um I'm actually curious like when
someone tags pomp in a story when
they're listening to podcasts like how's
that being managed are you just like you
have a team you have a person like
physically like looking and reposting
re-sharing no nothing it's just it's
just if I just see it which is wild
right yeah like literally 80 of and like
most of how we perceive information is
through stories yes these ephemeral
pieces of content yes and we realize
that like there are literally full-time
human jobs
screen saving this content tracking this
content and then maybe engaging with the
Creator be like hey can we use this
content and repurpose it and we're like
wait why is this like a full-time
person's job like like at Atrium and we
had a person doing this every day and it
was like stressful to like manage them
on Saturday whether they had to go on
vacation like ah someone's got to do
this
um
so we're like okay like more Computer
Science Guy let's build software to
automate it and that was a seat of
archive like let's automate the workflow
capture of all this Community Driven
events and now you know as we progress
and I think with increasing Focus where
there's companies like open store skins
it's very very sophisticated Community
oriented Brands can you automate like an
API to trigger automatic events so for
example one of our customers every time
an ambassador posts like an Instagram
story of like wearing this underwear or
wear wearing this clothing they want to
give like a a reward like a 10 20 ACH
stripe payment
well doing this manually sucks it's
essentially about scale of a thousand
people that you want to be tracking why
not build software automated so we're
just realizing that just this core
Insight of how do you actually go to
where the audience is where the
community is talking about a brand or a
product
um and build
web hooks build apis to actually trigger
software events around it has been a
very interesting opportunity yeah it's
um it's fascinating when you start to
understand that you were doing it with a
human yeah and then you just wrote the
software to automate that over time uh
are there other things that you all have
seen as you've built businesses where
humans are doing it you're like nah
that's definitely going to be software
you know two three years like why don't
we just go build it this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself an eat sleep you can
go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order eight
sleep dot com slash pomp not only do I
sleep on it every night it literally
changed my life and I begged the
founders to let me invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an eight
sleep pod and get a better night of
sleep I think that's like actually one
of the core themes of what we're looking
at with anti-fun and just horse over
like I think Jake and I spent a lot of
time
um I think we were actually like we want
to like start a company called 247
Industries that's literally like an AI
home security uh business because I
think Jake has a lot of personal stories
where he hires security guards that are
around his property that are just like
take falling asleep taking a nap you
know
um on that specific point uh this is
actually a thesis we'll talk about it
later uh I think that somebody's gonna
build a 21st century uh security
business but not a security business for
like businesses or uh even just uh uh
individual like homes where there's
cameras and stuff uh if you think of one
of a very large business that a lot of
people don't know about is uh bodyguards
Executives uh security all this stuff
and um in Miami for example a lot of
conferences so what happens is a bunch
of Executives fly here and some of them
will come with their own security but a
lot of them just want to use whatever
security is on the ground or or whatever
uh you see this in other uh uh uh cities
where there's a lot of Events Las Vegas
things like that go and search Miami
bodyguard on Google you'll be like I
think I just teleported back to 1995
because that's why well because it's
like you know look in in the people who
are running these businesses that's not
what they do they're not technologists
right so the so the websites are all
built on like WordPress they're not
updated they're like all these things
and so in some way uh there's an
opportunity just like go build a better
one but have a website that works right
what you're talking about though is like
no what if you reimagine the entire
thing yeah and you say hey from scratch
you know just like Andrew looked at was
a defense contractor looking like this
is you know what does this look like
from a technology standpoint to protect
someone's home to protect them to
protect their business yeah I mean I
think like yes I think that's like a one
specific instance but I think
that is going to be an inevitable
transformation I think like machine
learning AI I think you just see like
every single month there's just like a
breakthrough in terms of uh game playing
and what is physical reality but just
like a more complicated game than like a
little digital or a chessboard or a go
board I mean you're just adding more and
more degrees of freedom and it's like
okay the pro the progression seems quite
exponential right now are there more and
more jobs and and like and I think the
question is oh like are you destroying
people's livelihoods and it's like
yeah that is part of creative
destruction I I know I honestly don't
know if like a retail job is like
something that we should be happiest
Society be like hey like that is
someone's like passion to be in a retail
job
uh maybe it is but like maybe it's not
for a lot of people I don't think a lot
of retail job people are like yeah this
is my life's passion let's be real
um
so I think in terms of
transformation Market opportunity and
just efficiency I think those are going
to be some of the areas that will have a
lot of disruption and a lot of
opportunity there will be some
short-term pain as people transition but
I generally just believe in people's
resiliency right like
I just never understood like why like
longshoremen for these ports get to have
like this weird family like oligopoly
over like America's sports right like if
you just look at because I grew up in uh
LA County Palos Verdes a lot of friends
were like families of longshoremen
they're getting paid like a lot of money
to just like move uh crates off of boats
and and into trucks and ship them off
and like these unions are like very very
strong and it's and they're like and
like you can't even like I can't even
apply like like like the jobs get passed
on like family the Father the Son and
it's like wait this is like a weird
version of aristocracy where it's like
yo you were part of the original
longshoreman's group and Like You Gotta
Be You Gotta know them to like even get
that really well-paying job look I I I
support everyone making a livelihood but
is it like
do we actually want some like weird
Monopoly that's passed on through family
lineage to like monopolize like an area
that probably could use some updated
Machinery updated technology
um
I think the answer is yes because like
again to your point like why does every
Australian have to pay the queen it's
like well why does every American
citizen have to like get their I don't
know whatever their iPhone you know pay
these guys attacks when it's not a Fair
competition yeah when you look at
entrepreneurship today one of the types
of businesses that I'm fascinated by are
uh there's uh Trilogy there's
constellation uh um there is Tiny right
in kind of more of a tech oriented way
there's a lot of these that are popping
up now where people are going and
they're actually acquiring businesses
how do you guys think about buying
versus acquiring versus just investing
in like a minority stake
yeah I think that's like interesting
like oh like like debate that we
actually have I think acquiring business
is very hard because
one the infrastructure to maintain and
to retain the people that actually know
how to like improve the product is
actually quite tricky like being having
sold a company and being Amalgamated
into like the Borg of Groupon through my
first company glass map
I just saw like the
the very difficult challenges of like a
properly good M A integration right like
I think it's hard from an existing ego
perspective because like I remember I I
my palm is getting paid a lot more than
like my random co-workers I just went
through the front door and then like I
had like a bigger ego because I was like
oh I got I sold my company and I'm more
important and it's like wait like
I don't think he actually like those are
like the weird subtle dynamics of the
human personality side you know like I
think are under spoken about it with a
big m a kind of style play so having
been on the acquired side and thinking
about if I want to be an acquirer
um
I'm always very uh skeptical like why
are they showing to me now because like
they understand their business better
than I do and they're willing to sell it
to me like why they just sound kind of
sell to me there's like some broader
reason why our sentence is a line moving
forward I will feel more comfortable
about it but I think it's kind of
dangerous to be like I have a strict
information
disadvantage and are selling into me why
are you doing that
um
so I feel like
so like I've been much more on the sky
like building and incubating because I
feel like
um
maybe with the same amount of effort you
and and selection you can just go from
zero to like you know one two five
million of Revenue versus like hey I'm
gonna
spend five times ten times whatever
multiple whatever industry to buy
someone's thing and then maybe have to
rebuild the whole thing anyways yeah uh
that's an interesting point of like do
you think about starting businesses and
you're like hey the first goal is to get
like a million or five million dollars
and it's kind of Bottoms Up and like
let's get momentum or do you think about
you know is this a billion dollar
Revenue opportunity and then like back
into here's how we're gonna get to a
billion dollars in Revenue like is it
more master plan top down or is it more
um this is an interesting idea let's get
started build momentum is bottoms up I
think it's like the Paradox of having to
hold both States in your mind
um I think you so like I think you
always have to have like this narrative
this vision of a quiet this is like a
valuable problem that we're spending our
scarce resource of time on so yeah I
want to have this vision of like hey how
is this going to be a billion dollar
company that's worth all of our smart
brains and energies and limited uh
effort
um but I think when it's like pure
narrative I think that oftentimes is
very dangerous because like you just go
into like the atmosphere just raising a
bunch of money you don't actually like
make actual business
um so I think you choose a good market
and I think maybe better or sports
betting business is like a good case
study for this right sports betting
massive Market we think it's gonna be a
growing Market as more states legalized
sports betting
um
but like what is our first what is our
approach to literally get the first
state licensed and how do we acquire our
first a hundred one thousand ten
thousand users and have a really great
experience with them
um so I think that is like the challenge
in the art the Artistry of
Entrepreneurship how do you actually
have like this path this mining path to
like a billion dollar opportunity but
like don't get so full of your ego for
as a guilt you like you literally need
one person to like pay you money to like
keep the lights on
um
so if you can find and hold or have a
complimentary team where you can do both
I think that's almost required it's
insufficient to have one or the other
like what how do you get your first five
million of Revenue um
I see a lot of investors starting to
build companies again which is exciting
yeah uh but I also see a lot of
entrepreneurs who are uh previously they
had the dream they had the oh I'm gonna
go build the next you know Airbnb or
whatever business and in conversations
over the last six months market prices
come down I think reality kind of sets
in a little bit more uh there's more of
an acknowledgment of like Airbnb didn't
start off with like a multi-billion
dollar plan it started off with like I
have an air mattress in my kitchen yeah
and they're like selling like Captain
crunches or whatever to like pay the
bills absolutely and and so I do think
um uh goes back to kind of the saying of
like everything valuable starts off
looking like a toy right
um it feels like we are almost kind of
re-entering this like uh almost a
Renaissance of like real Founders and I
say real because uh there is this cohort
of like oh I think I'm a Founder so I
just go to conferences and networking
and all the [ __ ]
um and then like try to position myself
to be Forbes 30 under 30 and put it on
my LinkedIn uh versus
the people who are just like no like I
actually don't give a [ __ ] about any of
that stuff like I just want to figure
out how do I build something that like
people are willing to either use or buy
from me
um and that it like gets me very excited
it feels like oh now if you have ideas
like Now's the Time to [ __ ] go leave
your job quit whatever else you're
working on like go because for the next
two to three years you're gonna see like
this uh Capital injection in the early
stages you're gonna see a Renaissance of
all this stuff and five six seven years
from now we'll be talking about the
companies that are started right now
yeah I mean I think also just broadly I
think like the best investors I know I
think think of themselves as Founders I
think we're all just like building stuff
and I think if I when I was less mature
as an entrepreneur I would always look
at like VCS or investors as like oh
they're here to like give money and
support no it's like they're just as
much of a Savage business person as you
are and it's like yo it's just hard to
like build something that grows and
compounds and cash flows
um
so I think it's like a healthy
correction of expectations I don't blame
anyone because I think that was probably
the right strategy in in full bull
market like yo everyone was throwing
around money like crazy and I think
again I think when we're at hang out in
Miami over 20 20. I was like oh this is
a crazy time
um fun time it was like
and it's probably the right approach
just like tell a great story acquire
capital
just get long and loud right like like
literally that was what people were
doing I think uh Mark Cuban may be the
one who who said like in the 90s like
that was like an entire investment
strategy was just like get long and get
loud yeah and it feels like that that it
describes 2021 yeah was people were just
long every asset in the world like
they're like I just bought a [ __ ]
Beanie Baby I got a baseball card I got
this I got then everything's going on
and then it obviously you know yeah you
learn like hey you also got it's it's
not just like entry price but also sell
price right like I think I learned that
from a lot of my Wall Street New York
friends I feel like at least you're
probably kind of the same cloth I was
very much like a Founder accumulator
never hold never sell I think I
definitely learned a personal lesson in
terms of his you know we're also in the
business world where he also should
de-risk and take uh gains off the table
um so it's like a balance but I think to
your point I think it's great that
ultimately like what is I think business
like one thing I like to say is that a
lot of things are simple but not easy
like
make something that people will pay you
more money for than the cost you to
produce it's it's a super simple
statement but it's not easy to do and
easy to do at scale
um
and I think that like as more and more
people build like I'm I'm very
optimistic on capitalism and people's
creativity and people's like ambition
like when I look at that side of the
world I'm very optimistic and then I
look at the other news of like war and
crime I'm like kind of it's it's like
okay like there's the world is so big
you can kind of look at whatever you
want and you can tell yourself whatever
story you want and I think it's probably
like our own discipline
and almost our own self brainwashing our
self-religion which
where do you want to draw your attention
to and I think hopefully we can Inspire
more people to go towards building and
creating versus like hey like the
world's going to [ __ ] and like I gotta
like burn everything down yeah it um
it's an optimist view which I think uh
in technology is very persistent like
the technology industry is you have to
be an optimist it's very hard to be a
pessimist and and survive uh I do wonder
how much of the pessimistic view we see
outside of the technology industry uh is
kind of a point in time and the pendulum
swings back and people are like oh
pessimists you know they end up broken
depressed and like basically screwed
um and even if the ship is going down
being The Optimist is still a better
position to be in like The Optimist on
the sinking ship than to be the
pessimist in you know the the great
Empire because uh at the end of the day
uh you can only control so much and it's
like your mindset being you know one of
the most important things yeah I mean I
think it's important on the individual
level and important on a societal level
like I think
I think humans want to be part of the
winning team so I think it's like super
important if as you're thinking about
team formation or like nation state
construction like how do you create this
narrative that you're a force of good
force of positivity
um I think it's very dangerous when it's
like oh your country is like founded on
sin or it's like a bad position you've
got to tear everything down like like
how does that allow you to build and
create value right like
and then I think it's like it feels very
value extractive very versus like value
accretive and at a certain point like if
we're just like looking at our
neighbor's stuff
and trying to take stuff
I don't know if that's like that world I
want to be in right like I think I'm I'm
more mindful of that because I feel like
there are I feel like there are
definitely just segments of
every country but I think especially in
America where it's like very ex like
value extractive like hey we need to
like punish people and I think that's
like I don't know if like that's the
direction of the country we want to go
in yeah I um uh I could not agree more
uh when you look out over the next five
years or so what are you most excited
about uh in terms of uh investing and
building companies
um
I think
on the maybe like just like just like
just fresh like just approach in terms
of strategy shift yeah I think last year
was like go along everything I mean I
think we've I know we've just shared
stories which is like just crazy deals
just flying around things getting like
oversubscribed in like 24 hours just
fire stuff everywhere
um I think the mood and and focus now is
um
be really involved incubate get on the
ground floor with in markets or problems
that we think that we have a special
understanding of or just are big
Believers in so I think AI machine
learning and their applications into
like very verticalized applications is
very interesting
um I think especially with Jake with
Sport and media I think there's a lot of
interesting applications and I think
this better is is one manifestation of
that how do you get the modern version
of some of these entertainment products
in community products
um
and then I think
and then so like focusing a lot of
incubation sort of super super early
stage like ground floor level
co-founding starting these things from
scratch
or just like backing like
post product Market fit post Revenue
like companies like anderill or like
things like Alchemy which is like a web
3 infrastructure company
um I think it's increasingly hard to be
in no man's land which is that like you
don't have enough ownership or control
or
moral Authority be like really that
engaged with the company
but it's also like not post product
Market fit where you know our expertise
with marketing branding like really can
is they're still finding product Market
fit
um so I think the
philosophy and is like hey polarized
position like really understand are you
and are we in category one or category
two
and be very very polite about like hey
just you know anything else is not in
our Focus area it's a barbell strategy
and uh I think why you and I get along
so well is like almost to a t that's how
I see the world yeah it's like there are
a very small number of companies that
you will not build but are Grand Slam
opportunities and you have to be uh uh
aware of them and be able to get access
to them sometimes you're aware and you
can't get access sometimes you could get
access but nobody told you or whatever
right
um and so uh in those opportunities like
it makes sense to essentially make
angel-like investments or or kind of
fund Investments where you're a minority
kind of passive uh participant and
there's some great Capital uh uh
compounding that can occur
but I think it's a white you know kind
of uh slate in terms of the building
side and my guess is that the next
cohort of really big companies people
are going to be shocked by who's
building them because it's not going to
be uh you know some some of the same
types of people like the patterns are
about to get broken and uh that is
healthy uh but also the best investors
they're not going to be caught
flat-footed like I already see them
they're like oh okay World shifting like
there's certain other people you know
how many investors are like I'll give Mr
Beast any amount of money he wants to
build companies yeah like there's
actually a number of them that are very
intelligent they realize okay the world
is Shifting now this guy actually uh is
you know is Mr Beast the new white
combinator
like it's a different model it's a
different way of doing it it's different
value proposition but
y combinator has been incredibly
successful at being able to put
companies through and find success
it's gonna be hard-pressed to find
someone who's doing it at a level that
he's doing it right now right and so
it's like an interesting thing because
with Y commoner you can invest in their
funds you could put companies through
like all this stuff with Mr Beast it may
not be as clear as to how do you benefit
from that financially if you're just a
passive investor who's got Capital yeah
no I mean this is what I said I said
I've always said that Paul Graham's the
best entrepreneur in Silicon Valley over
the last 20 years probably I mean I mean
just straight up like he literally is a
multi-billionaire alert has stakes in
some of the most iconic companies built
out of Silicon Valley and just made
himself an institution right and and
like I think the way he succeeds is like
you don't even think of him as an
entrepreneur he's just like the nice
principal Guru and it's like it's part
of the substrate of Silicon Valley like
he succeeded so damn well that he's
invisible and people don't even think of
him as like a prophet collector
um I just remember like all like he was
like the only LP or besides like Sequoia
for like a lot of the initial funds I
mean the guy
argue he made one of the best companies
over the last 20 years and I think
people
don't even consider them an entrepreneur
which is like the super interesting jiu
jitsu movie like Aikido move where it's
like
he's a silent killer like he won
it is pretty freaking impressive right
like people don't think of him as an
entrepreneur yeah but why combinators
got to be worth a couple billion dollars
easy yeah I mean if you just have a few
points of stripe Airbnb drop I mean just
name to go down that list
[ __ ] and he's like the main LP of all
these funds huh okay yeah it is
absolutely insane uh where can we send
people find you on the internet uh find
out more about the companies uh I'm
available at Jeffrey Wu Geo f f r e y w
o Instagram Twitter
um anti-fund hvmn archive
better better be ETR
we're available just Google yeah I
always appreciate talking to you thank
you so much we'll do it again in the
future yeah it's awesome